You would think that drawing every frame of
animation, or creating entire digital movie
sets one pixel at a time would make it easier
to avoid mistakes or accidents.
But some of the most well-known animated movies
have incredible mistakes that fans probably
never noticed… until now.
We’ve done a couple of Movie Mistakes videos
and if you’re a fan stick around until the
end for links to those other great videos!
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Biggest Movie Mistakes
You Missed In Disney Films.
Toy Story 2
When two of the starring toys of Pixar's flagship
series have a conversation in front of a TV
screen, a mistake on the animators' part left
fans with two strange explanations.
Either the animators forgot to put the toys'
reflections in the TV screen, or the movie
has been following the ghosts of long dead
toys this entire time.
We'd like to think it was a mistake, but the
second answer is obviously more exciting.
Frozen
Considering the awards it racked up for its
soundtrack and singing, you would think that
Frozen was flawless when it came to music.
Instruments were a different story.
Kristoff's four string guitar gives fans a
funny song, but with only three tuning pegs
to match, the missing peg is a mistake no
musician could miss.
Cinderella
Even Disney princesses aren't immune to wardrobe
malfunctions, or stealthy costume changes
without explanation.
Cinderella's long sleeve wedding dress is
hard to forget - especially since a similar
design was used in the real royal wedding.
But after the wedding, Cinderella's dress
suddenly becomes sleeveless.
Apparently two different animators are to
blame, since the color of the carriage's drapes
changes color to make the mistake even easier
to spot.
Tangled
Nobody could have guessed that Eugene would
make the ultimate sacrifice, slicing off Rapunzel's
magical hair to keep her from saving his life.
Apparently, even the animators were a little
caught up in the scene to pay attention to
detail.
There's clearly a large metal shackle attached
to his wrist throughout the scene.
But when he raises a hand to give Rapunzel
one last touch, it's magically disappeared.
It's not a massive mistake, but in a movie
without many, it's easy to spot.
Pocahontas
We're going to skip over the historical inaccuracy
of this Disney story, since one small mistake
is still enough to make viewer's heads hurt.
Shadows can be tricky things in animated and
CG movies, since they can bend, distort, or
overlap in tricky ways.
But one thing's for sure: when Pocahontas
and Nakoma are walking holding hands, the
shadows that precede them should definitely
be doing the same.
Maybe there was more magic going on in this
story than we ever realized....
Wreck-it Ralph
The story of a bad guy turned hero ends on
a sweet note, with Ralph letting us know that
the best part of his day is being tossed off
a building, when its tenants lift him up high
enough to see his friend Vanellope in the
game Sugar Rush.
It's a touching idea to wrap up the story,
but it isn't exactly true.
Earlier in the movie, it's made pretty clear
that Ralph can see the entire Sugar Rush game
from farther down the apartment building.
Maybe it's the thought that counts.
Frozen
A missing peg is one thing, but how about
a disappearing sword?
When Hans tells Elsa that her sister has been
killed by her magic, it's obvious he doesn't
have any weapons with him out on the ice.
But just moments later, you can hear the sound
of a weapon being drawn - a massive sword
- that wasn't there before.
And he still isn't wearing a sheath that would
have made the sound to being with.
Ice isn't the only magic at work.
Monsters, Inc.
It's one thing to claim that monsters can
use closet doors to travel across the globe
in a few seconds, but something else to say
they have mastery over time itself.
The chase scene through the warehouse full
of doors is exciting, but take a second look
at the locations the stars travel.
For starters, it's night time when they start
in Nepal, then again when they head to Florida.
If that wasn't enough of a problem, it's also
the middle of the day in Paris, the South
Pacific, and Japan.
Ratatouille
There's plenty of actual culinary expertise
for the food fans underneath the action of
this Pixar hit, and even some chef humor thrown
in for good measure.
When food critic Anton Ego remembers his last
review of Gusteau's restaurant, he uses one
of the world' most famous chefs to insult
the establishment.
Audiences are meant to take it as a slam against
the face of American canned pasta and sauce,
but Hector Boyardee wasn't just a mascot for
the brand, but an award winning chef at New
York's Plaza Hotel, years before he started
selling his food to the public.
He would even receive special honors from
both the USA and Russia for feeding troops
during World War 2.
Which means Ego's insult... would actually
be a massive compliment.
Now THERE's some food for thought.
Wreck-it Ralph
There's also a much bigger oversight later
in the movie, when Vanellope and Ralph succeed
in getting the candy-speckled girl across
the finish line, resetting the game to the
way it should be, with Vanellope now a princess,
and King Candy's invading influence wiped
clean.
It's a happy ending, but the artists must
have missed the memo: King Candy's logo and
face can still be seen just as they were when
he was ruling.
Those are some of our favorite mix-ups, mistakes
and errors in Disney films, but which ones
have we missed?
Let us know in the comments and be sure to
check out our other movie mistakes videos
by clicking on the link on the top right!
If you want to be part of it all, subscribe
to our channel for more videos about amazing
movie secrets!
Thanks!